i want to thank you all for joining me
on our fantastic speakers
today i have negan shawn lauren baker
matthew lundgren
serena young and tina hernandez wissart
from the ai and healthcare
specialization here with me
thank you all for being with us today dr
negan shaw is an associate professor of
medicine biomedical informatics at
stanford university
and serves as the associate cio for data
science first stanford healthcare
professor lawrence baker is the bing
professor of human biology
and professor in the health policy group
at stanford university
dr lundgren is the co-director of the
stanford center for artificial
intelligence and medicine and imaging
and medical school faculty in the
department of radiology at stanford
university medical center
professor serena young is an assistant
professor
of biomedical data science and by
courtesy of computer science and of
electrical engineering at stanford
university
she's also affiliated with stanford's
clinical excellence research center
and serves as associate director of data
science
for the center for artificial
intelligence in medicine and
imaging dr hernandez broussard
is an associate professor at stanford
university in medicine biomedical
informatics
biomedical data science surgery and
epidemiology and population health by
courtesy
thank you all for joining us today and i
will now turn it over to professor baker
to begin
our presentation good morning
everyone hi let's see let me get myself
organized here i am
very excited to be here and to be able
to talk to you all about our
uh our program and my particular part in
it
uh i am teaching a course on the
healthcare system
in this so uh the u.s uh the use of ai
and and informatics tools and healthcare
offers huge opportunities
to the healthcare system uh and to
developers and innovators but it's
important to come at this
in the context of understanding the
healthcare system and how the healthcare
system works
ai and data efforts more generally
interact with systems healthcare systems
involving national and
regional local even individual
healthcare providers
and the ways that they provide and
finance care in a couple of
important ways one is that developers
and innovators
need to produce solutions that can help
and be of interest to system
participants if they're going to use
them
the other way they interact is that they
use data
developers uh innovators use data from
entities that are in the health care
system and and they need to understand
what the data is and and where the data
comes from
so we're going to spend some time
thinking about that familiarizing you
with the parts of the healthcare system
so you can better participate with it
get some expertise in what's going on we
go through a perspective on a lot of
health care systems we mostly take the
perspective of the u.s
system since there's a lot of complexity
there to work with but along the way
we're going to try to get you up to
speed on information
and an understanding of systems that
could be useful in many places around
the world
we spend time in in a couple of
different areas you see
some of them here on this first slide
there are a wide variety of healthcare
providers
in a healthcare system doctors physician
assistants
nurse practitioners nurses technicians
dentists ophthalmologists optometrists
all sorts of different folks
and they work in a lot of different
kinds of organizations
you see here i've got some small ones um
individual physician clinics where maybe
a couple of physicians work
small practices single hospitals and all
the way up to
really large systems where you see
hospitals and physicians and a lot of
different providers
labs imaging all in the same
organization we're going to try to
unpack that for you a lot of variety
a lot of things changing but what
happens when we grow these larger
organizations
how do they think about data what kind
of data do they produce what kind of
solutions do they want what about the
small ones
we're going to try to take a look at
that
there's been a lot of uh of interest in
trying to understand how that's been
happening in different systems then
these
entities work with payers right you see
in the middle of my slide there
private insurance companies uh
government organizations
uh these folks keep the funds flowing in
a lot of cases and do other management
and regulation we're going to try to
unpack
that for you so you can get a sense for
how these organizations are
are working what they're doing and then
on the right you see a whole bunch of
other entities that are out there
they may be government regulators like
the food and drug administration
the ema in europe they may be pharma or
biotech companies
medical devices they may be pharmacies
there are a whole variety
of other entities that produce
healthcare that produce data
that need innovations from all of us all
of you all
to be to do their job really effectively
and provide really high quality care
and so those are the kinds of things we
try to figure out we're going to look
inside those organizations
what kind of data is being generated by
by physicians when they take care of
patients that developers and innovators
can use what about medical records
and how those data that can be extracted
from those
might be available for for new
innovations what about payment data
when people send bills and get money
back we're going to try to track how the
funds flows
the funds flow between different
entities and try to really get into that
really interesting and exciting areas
where there's been a lot of change
and a ton of opportunity uh when we get
to the end of that i hope you
hope you'll feel like you have a sense
for some of these different
organizations how they work
uh what's been happening what are the
rules and regulations that they respond
to
and why would they want your products
and why would they want your uh
your innovations how would you make that
work for them
we're also going to look uh spend some
time on pharma farm is a different
a different entity if you will so we
think a lot about
um uh
the way oh yeah no pharma we so we think
a lot about drug pricing drug
innovations
uh device innovations drug pricing and
how that works
uh in this in this course after thinking
about other kinds of healthcare
providers
you see a little slide here we've got to
understand how
manufacturers get involved drug
manufacturers but then how they
send the drugs around the system if we
want to track who's using what
uh how distributors get involved we send
new products to distributors
out to retailers like pharmacies local
pharmacies out to patients
and data is generated in there and
solutions are needed in there in terms
of understanding what's going on with
the distribution
how to optimize that how to help
patients get the best medicines
at the same time in the blue there's a
lot of things going on with pharmacy
benefit management with
private and public payers so insurance
companies and that
in the groups that they work with so you
need to understand some of that if
you're going to try to use data or try
to create
stories or try to create products that
can build off of the stories of need
from these different areas
you need to know what a pharmacy benefit
manager is you need to know what a
switch
is you need to know what some of these
different entities are and we're going
to try to tell you that
i get you through some of these areas
where you can understand the
funds flows uh and the the structural
flows in delivering healthcare
the last thing that we're going to spend
some time on is quality measurement
in terms of trying to figure out what's
going on in this particular area we talk
about some of the structures things
people are trying to measure
we say sometimes structural measurement
is one piece of it what kind of
entities are out there in the healthcare
system and how are they organized
sometimes we think processes are part of
that what kinds of activities are people
taking to try and improve quality to
deliver the best care to their patients
and then what about outcomes do people
live longer are people
made healthy faster can we measure those
kinds of things tons of attention
to trying to measure quality and in some
of these different areas produce
data and then process it try to
understand what
creates quality what what entities are
doing a good job
what kinds of new techniques and and i
don't know
quantitative work uh regulations might
drive quality so
uh huge opportunities for people who are
interested in the
medical care system interested in
innovations uh
in order to drive better quality
lots of data being produced by these
that you can use so we'll walk through
this we'll try to understand how these
um processes work we'll try to
understand what the opportunities are
and try to set you up to be able to
interact with this part of the
healthcare system
and current efforts as well at the end
of the day uh you know health care
systems aren't complicated
uh but you can understand important
pieces of them and you can really get
your uh
get your bearings with respect to the
kinds of organizations that are out
there
what they're trying to do uh what kind
of data they're creating and what kinds
of solutions that they want and we want
to provide that foundation
in this course for you i'm really
excited to teach it uh really excited to
to have you all interested in this area
and
something we have something that really
i hope can set the stage for the further
work
in this particular program so with that
i'm going to pass it off
uh that's that's what my course does i'm
delighted to be able to talk with you
today and i really hope to see some of
you in class
so welcome everyone and this class is
about
ai in healthcare and therefore we begin
with healthcare and one of the
major differences from most other
project most of the classes you might
experience
is that we first introduce what the
health care system
is and you know lauren described it in a
few slides
but the class will really walk you
through what's the anatomy
who does what what data they generate
and
we need that reference that context
before we can begin
understanding what we can do with those
data using artificial intelligence
so what i'm going to do now is to give
you a little bit of a preview
that assuming you've understood sort of
the main parts of the healthcare
ecosystem
and you know the data coming out of the
different parts of it
how should we think about those data
what are those clinical data that we
might get our hands on
so for example imagine this
timeline of a patient and i
suggest this as a useful construct to
organize the thinking
because multiple entities in the
healthcare system will produce
information
but that information is tied to a human
being
the patient and what we're seeing on
screen is sort of
a cartoon where we have a timeline going
from left to right and those little
circles are
things that of of healthcare consequence
that happened
and then underneath that are the
different kinds of data i've just shown
a few examples about eight or nine on
this one
uh the diagnosis codes you might get the
laboratory test results medications
the textual documents a physician might
write uh
you know streaming data you might hear
about genomic data imaging obviously
which is uh you know where ai has a lot
of
implications and applications uh you
might get
signals from bedside monitors and so on
so having this
frame of reference of imagining this
longitudinal record and what happens is
that
each different entity gives you like one
square
if you have a prescription that happened
at a particular event
you went to a pharmacy the pharmacy has
a record the hospital
uh has a record of ordering it the the
pharmacy switch that routed it has the
record
eventually your insurance company also
has a record and so it's like four or
five records
of one event and depending on where you
get that
you might even get slightly different
information that's really important to
understand
so we'll walk you through that so let's
look a little bit closer
the timeline has multiple types of data
diagnosis codes laboratory test results
in the screen it's kind of hard to see
but in the class we'll actually walk you
through with real examples
i've only shown four here lab results
medications
documents that a doctor might write and
diagnose these codes
and then once we've sort of gracked and
understood
the kinds of data at our disposal and
have organized them into this conceptual
view then we step into what are the
questions
and that's another differentiator that
is instead of jumping straight to the ai
in machine learning
we first walk you through the kinds of
questions that need to be answered
so here's an example
meet laura she's a teenager with
systemic lupus erythromytosis or sle
uh and presented with protein urea
meaning there's a protein in her urine
has pancreatitis and is positive for
this uh
laboratory test for anti-phospholipid
antibodies
our goal is to use these data to provide
better care
and in this particular case what we
would be doing
is getting with
starting with all the patients that's
that big circle
sort of all our data we identify those
individuals that are teenagers that's
that orange circle
uh those that might have pancreatitis
protein urea sle those are those other
circles
and in the end we get to
the set of patients that match our
description
now in this case it's uh kind of hard to
see
but what i've highlighted is this
tiny slice of patients that match
all of the criteria for what we're
interested in
to inform the care of this particular
patient and remember in doing this
exercise we also have to worry about the
time axis
that we have to make sure that these
things happened in a certain
order and all of those operations and
understanding how to do them with data
or probably eighty percent of the work
before you get to the ai and to the
modeling
and time spent here uh essentially
determines
the degree of success in being able to
answer the question that you seek to
answer
and then ultimately get to improving
healthcare using the eye
and so to surround out this portion of
the course you know on the left here on
this particular screen our
is a patient timeline a sort of a
compact view
with all of the different data types
that we're going to be talking about
and you know summarize this sort of this
yellow block of patient timelines
because we have these on multiple human
beings
and then we're going to be using these
timelines
and operations on them to basically
inform
two kinds of decisions whether to treat
and how to treat in the previous example
the decision to be made was for a
patient like that
we were trying to ascertain is the
person
at high risk of a thrombotic event as in
getting blood clots in their feet
and if that risk is high we would then
decide to treat
that patient with anticoagulation it's a
decision of
whether to treat also known as risk
stratification
risk estimation you can do that using
classifiers predictors and all sorts of
other ways of
of estimating them and we're not going
to talk about the decisions about how to
treat today
uh but i just want to lay out this la
this landscape that
with using these information in this
data sets you can be answering these two
categories of questions
both of which can be informed using ai
and the fundamentals of that are what uh
dr serena young and matthew lundgren are
going to walk you through
all right thanks and i'm matt
lundgren i'm going to talk a little bit
about
um our course along with serena young um
and our course is entitled fundamentals
and machine learning
in healthcare and um you know again i
think a lot of
healthcare as we've sort of touched on
already is
you know focused on data information and
you know we try to take a step back and
say you know
it's not just a hospital encounter or
it's not just
you know one aspect it's really the
entire ecosystem together
that comprises um you know the the
playing field of opportunities for
machine learning and healthcare but
um not everybody who is going to be
using these tools or developing these
tools
will have to have deep expertise in any
one area in other words this isn't a
this is a very much a multidisciplinary
field
and so the purpose behind sort of
constructing this
course is really to try to focus on uh
both the clinical perspective and this
the computer science or machine learning
perspective that's where
both dr young and i uh contribute and
you know again this is about sort of
understanding from your domain so
whether you're in
global health or you're in pharma or
you're in radiology or you're in
a pharmacy understanding the concepts
and principles behind these tools and
technologies
such that you can comfortably evaluate
potentially contribute to a team or
development a project around
a use case in your domain expertise area
or again be able to conversationally
understand
the inner workings of a lot of these
things that ultimately we all recognize
will be a major part of healthcare
going forward and again that's
irrespective of exactly which
discipline you're in i happen to be a
radiologist uh
recognizing that i see a lot of
applications that are
you know sort of taking place in my
field having the
understanding of where these tools will
work
where they won't work what biases may be
present how to evaluate them critically
that's really what this course is really
going to help you understand and
and again the the road map here uh is
really sort of taking the the larger
view
understanding again your domain where
that intersects with some of the
applications that exist currently but
then as you can see here
recognizing that no matter whether
you're working with structured data
pixel or imaging data um or with you
know
text report free text data and other
types of data like you know native had
touched upon in his course uh wearables
and other types of
genomic data you need to find a way to
frame that data and then how it would
work within a given
uh machine learning construct and so
again this course is really to sort of
give you that
background arm you with the expertise
so that you can critically understand
develop and analyze
these tools in your own area of
expertise or domain and that's really
the purpose here so you can see here
whether you're working with structured
data again pixel data we need to boil it
down
and understand which models would work
for which types of data
where those advantages are and again how
to apply them into practice
um hi everyone i'm serena young the
other co-instructor for this course
um and so just continuing from what what
matt was saying you know
we'll be spending a portion of this
course kind of introducing the
fundamental
computer science concepts as well behind
some of these machine learning
algorithms
that can be used
uh different types of prediction tasks
on these diverse types of data
and we'll cover kind of the fundamentals
that will enable you to
to make good decisions about using to
develop these models
for various types of ai applications in
healthcare and so there's really a large
toolbox of algorithms that
generally you can you can pick from and
these include both traditional machine
learning algorithms
such as regression based uh methods
decision trees support vector machines
and others
and there's also a recent class of very
popular algorithms
called deep learning algorithms um and
in particular variants as well
for for visual visual data for sequence
data
um and so we're going to cover all of
these different types of algorithms uh
the fundamentals
of what they mean i mean importantly the
trade-offs
and thinking about how to choose the
right right model for your
uh for your application and so we'll
look at trade-offs like
uh you know some of them may have a
better performance
on certain kinds of tasks other
algorithms may be more interpretable
some algorithms may require certain it
may perform better in certain types of
data or
require certain size of data and so
we'll discuss all these different
uh trade-offs as you're thinking about
how to choose
the right algorithm and what exactly how
exactly these algorithms
work and then the on the flip side
uh equally important to choosing the
right algorithm is also being able to
evaluate your models
appropriately once you actually uh train
uh train your algorithms
um and uh and and so you know this is
this is a really
important part because uh different
models uh can
perform differently on on uh different
use cases and so some may be better in
certain
scenarios and others may be better um
for other scenarios
and so just as one example for example
in
in this graph here if you have the same
let's say false positive rate
model a might have better sensitivity
than model b
and so you might you know want to use
model a in this case
but let's say you're willing to take a
bit of a higher false uh false positive
rate um let's say you have some sort of
screening application
well maybe in this case model b actually
has a better sensitivity
in this case and so uh the model that
you might prefer to use uh
can be can be really different depending
on your application
so we're going to go into these these
different ways of evaluating these these
models
um things to think about as well as
particular
uh traps that you you want to make sure
that you're aware of as well
some nuanced questions such as biases in
the data
and so we'll talk about the different
pitfalls and how to think about these
these questions of evaluation carefully
ultimately this is a
again a multi-disciplinary endeavor and
so you know we try to frame this course
uh with that in mind so again whether
your background is
you know heavily technical whether your
background is
heavily clinical or somewhere in between
all across the healthcare spectrum
there is value in this course uh in
learning about the concepts and
principles that we're trying to
sort of outline and then recognizing at
the end as we sort of tie things
together
how you can build multi-disciplinary
teams
in order to accomplish your goals and
again those goals could be in almost any
aspect of health care but some of the
fundamentals
and principles will remain the same so
we're really excited to sort of present
that course to all of you and we hope
that
you take away from it something that
really impacts your practice and your
careers
and i'll turn it over to tina what my
module does my module is the final
module in the ai and healthcare course
and really what i try and do is build
upon all the other modules that we've
just heard from
and in particular in this module i
present key components of model
evaluation
deployment and regulation so
one thing i think is important to
understand
is that the majority of ai models
developed in healthcare end with a
publication
reporting model performance and
generally they are not deployed
so in this model we tackle other forms
of model evaluation that are critical to
deployment or implementation that are
necessary to
prevent unintended consequences of
deployed ai solutions in healthcare
in the first lessons i provide a
framework to better evaluate ai
models a framework that moves beyond
model performance and highlights the net
benefit
of the model to end users so in this
framework
we talk about understanding what cl the
clinical utility of your model
who receives the model output who will
benefit from the model output
and is there a mitigating action that
can be taken upon the out
on the output so say for example i've
developed
a classifier that identifies cancer
patients at high risk of suicidal
tendencies
so the care team might use this model
that's who receives the output
to allocate additional social service
supports that's the mitigating action
to help those cancer patients with
suicidal tendencies so they are the
beneficiaries
the next step in thinking about these
evaluations is assessing the feasibility
of a model
so can i get this model deployed at
point of care and there's
many steps to thinking about deployment
and and the feasibility so here we
review
important questions such as are the data
i need to run the model available in a
timely manner and in a translatable
format
um you know what are the implementation
costs who is going to actually work on
the it
team to get this information that i need
in in a reasonable time
frame um what are the implementation
costs
and and importantly what are the post
deployment challenges
um thinking about you know who is going
to be responsible for the maintenance
and monitoring of the model over time
so in the previous example if we've
identified
patients advanced cancer patients with
suicidal tendencies
can i get this data and process it
before the patient's upcoming
appointment
are there enough team members to connect
with those patients
what we don't want to do is deploy a
model and identify patients who might
have suicidal tendencies but then not
have the resources or capacity
to provide services to those patients
finally we discussed the um the clinical
impact of the ai solution
and this could be measured in a number
of ways including improved patient
outcomes
uh cost savings reduction of clinical
burden etc
so importantly utility feasibility and
impact all need to be assessed before
considering
implementation or deployment of a model
um and so in addition as i mentioned
you know the majority of ai models
developed in health care and with a
publication and never
get to point of care and this is likely
because there are many critical barriers
to deployment
so in this class i discussed the
deployment pathway that highlights
several critical steps that are
necessary for deployment which starts at
the conception of the idea
this includes as as others have said in
the course you know stakeholder
involvement during the design
and development state are you asking the
right question that can be answered with
the data you have
a thorough evaluation of the model prior
to deployment
including assessing utility feasibility
and impact
and a deep understanding of how the end
user will use this output in your model
is necessary
finally we talk about the need for
prospective evaluation of the model
before going live so you can deploy the
the the model at point of care
and just view it in silence and how you
are
predicting patients and how people are
are using that information
um and finally we review stages related
to how you would scale your model to
address generalizability and external
validity
again a critical barrier to deployment
is the continuous
monitoring and maintenance of the model
over time so here in this course i
provide you with insight on how you can
use the output of your model to
continuously
improve its clinical impact and
usability
now of course we can't speak about model
evaluation
without discussing bias and algorithmic
fairness
so understanding the different types of
bias that can infiltrate into your data
and therefore your model are essential
to help mitigate their effects in
healthcare delivery
so in this course i i go through all the
different types well i go through
several different types of bias that can
be entered in the data
and we provide some fairness algorithms
to how to mitigate those
now i'm a big fan of reporting standards
such as the minimal information for
medical ai reporting or minimar
and if the data you use to train your
model are biased
and most likely they are or if there are
issues with their model architecture at
a minimum this information needs to be
transparently reported
so that the end user or other users know
how to implement your model
know how to apply it to different
populations and here i discussed the
different types
of ways that we can report these
standards and the type of information
that needs to be
um reported
and finally i discussed the regulatory
environment for ai solutions and
healthcare
now this is definitely a moving field
and and quickly evolving but it's
important to understand the rules and
regulations
set out by the us um food and drug
administration or the fda
and their their aspects of model
regulation
so importantly in this module um i
highlight the fda's regulations on
software as a medical
device and the different pathways to
regulation
in addition we discuss the regulation in
other countries so for example the
european union
and and china and understanding
and and use that to understand the
commonalities and the differences of the
global environment
so at the end of this module the user
should have a good understanding of how
to thoroughly evaluate an ai solution
beyond model performance
in healthcare and understand a pathway
to deployment and regulation
so thank you great thank you so
much tina um thank you all of our
faculty
for joining us today and for their
presentations
and we will move on to the q a and ask
our faculty some questions here
um first question is actually regarding
the
overall program um and someone had asked
can someone join the program
even if they don't have a diploma in a
healthcare domain
but rather in science such as biology or
chemistry
i'm going to leave it up to to you all
to add to that whoever wants to kind of
jump in and answer that question
well i'll jump in and just uh and just
say from the perspective of my course
one of the reasons that we include a
course
on the health care system in this whole
program
is that we can get you that kind of
knowledge right we can bring if you've
got a science background if you've got a
technical background
and you want to work in the healthcare
space one of the things that i'm really
hoping to do is give you some
exposure to an understanding of the
different entities in healthcare and how
they work
so that you can take your technical
knowledge and your experience and your
interest in those areas and apply them
to this particular area so i'd say
absolutely
come and take get involved in the
program if you're interested we'll try
to get you
up to speed on the things that you need
to know and then as
my fellow faculty carried forward in the
program i think there's also a lot of
uh exposure there to the particulars of
health care and how that might work and
so i think in a lot of ways this should
be perfect for you if you're interested
in this and
should really try to give you the
foundation background
thank you lauren um the next question
similar is the course suitable for
people who are beginners in
programming um and you might want
to kind of jump in on this one
and share your thoughts absolutely so
yeah this part this particular class
actually does not
require you to program yourself
in fact one of the uh things we do in
the final capstone project
is we walk you through code step by step
giving examples of this is the kind of
thing you would need to learn or do
if you were to do this kind of analyses
yourself so it's a gentle introduction
where you we first share the concepts
well we first share the why
then we share the what and then we get
to the how
and then follow on courses in
programming will then make more sense
absolutely i think if there's no prior
programming experience it should be
feasible to enroll and complete this
class successfully
great thank you i mean i just want to
add on to that that also you know for
our discussion of machine learning
algorithms
um are it also you know doesn't require
any programming because we're focusing
on
uh how these algorithms work and
from a conceptual standpoint in
particular what you need to know
in order to be able to make decisions
about what algorithms to choose
um and then how to uh to then you know
once uh when someone is training the
algorithms
how to actually think about uh how good
the algorithms are and then how to
deploy them and so
a lot of the focus is around decision
making uh
uh with it with a basic fundamental
understanding of how the algorithms work
great thank you and last question
regarding the overall program
um do you have hands-on sessions in the
program
for instance you students actually get
to develop ai solutions for healthcare
so maybe tina can take that regarding
the capstone yes
absolutely yeah so in the capstone at
the end of the four modules we've
developed a capstone course that brings
everything together
and and and provides um a use case of
how
um and it's actually um um written in
the form of you
have um somebody going to their
supervisor talking about
wanting to deploy a model and walking
through all of these hurdles that we
discuss
um throughout the different modules and
so it gives
the user an opportunity to really
understand
where these where these barriers arise
how you can resolve them and give them
real use case examples of that
um so so yes the capstone product is
really well-rounded across the four
modules
thank you and then this next question
here is actually
regarding um lauren's presentation
and i think this is regarding slide 14
lauren
um and someone was asking uh r
or python
r or python slide
14 i don't i'm trying to get this slide
14 a minute
um i just so my class doesn't
particularly deal with the programming
languages
uh that you would need to use or the
statistical languages that you would
need to use to work on some of these
solutions
uh we're trying to get you an exposure
to the all the different things that are
out there and so i think
our and python could both be relevant uh
in different particular ways so uh so i
think um
i'm trying to get people ready to
interact with the healthcare system
in in really productive and interesting
ways and i think that could be done in a
lot of ways so
i don't know if my other faculty want to
discuss but i thought i think
our python are both good for my from my
perspective
yeah so i'll jump in here uh both r
and python are about the how uh once
you've figured out the
particular question you wish to ask
you know you know pick whichever one is
the more
closer to your existing working paradigm
i mean there's certain things that are
definitely easier in python if you're
manipulating images or
text you probably won't be in python uh
but if you're doing with the categorical
numerical data r works fine too
and this is regarding niggum's
presentation
how big of a role does blockchain play
in integrating the different parts of
the healthcare system and across various
global systems
at the moment not much uh at least in
the u.s
i mean there's a lot of talk about
blockchain but the majority of data sets
today
available are you and you might be
surprised but are shared with you either
as csv files or database tables
of some sort uh you know perhaps you
might get to that blockchain future but
we're not there yet
and um where and how is the data
collected
is it all within the emr and can you
correlate databases
with emr data
so the data that you we talk about
are not necessarily just ehr data
so for example as lauren baker mentioned
uh the pharmacy switch um
and data from the pair they're not in
the ehr
and we will talk about those data sets
and those sources
and then if you adopt this timeline view
you can imagine
that in order to get the complete
picture of what
happened you need to get information
from the ehr
you need to get information from the
payer and perhaps you might also need to
get some information from the patient
which currently there's no scalable
ways of doing that but increasingly as
the use of data by patients directly
increases
we will find ways of getting those data
items as well
so i would encourage you to think of
data holistically and not just from
one source ideally you want to stitch
the timeline across
all the players that in the health care
system
that collect information about an
individual
okay and the next question is um
i really think that clinical ai and
personalized medicine is conditioned by
a global medical
system otherwise the models simply won't
generalize what are the thoughts of the
experts
on this panel on this topic and given
the difficulty to create this universal
system
is a robust healthcare ai system an
unrealistic
objective
i can go ahead and take a stab at that
one so i think it depends on the
question you're trying to answer with
the ai
um and and so the health care systems
are are
very different um globally even
even nationally we find enormous
difference for example
in the way we triage patients for covid
or the way
we were um doing other types of hospital
management so it really depends on the
question you're asking
um if you're looking at diagnosis of
disease then yeah we see
and maybe matt can speak to this in in
radiology or image control or seeing
global um shared algorithms in in that
system
but globally um you know it is really
dependent on the question you're asking
and is it applicable to the global
market or or is it something for your
particular health care system
yeah i i'd probably add to that you know
there are certain types of data and
certain specialties that might be
slightly more amenable to the
applications here but but um and that's
one of the things we cover in our course
i think initially there's a lot of
there's a sense of you know this model
works here or works in this paper
it must work everywhere i think that's
still a misconception we
we go in pretty deep on this in our
course just really try to
uh tease out some of the aspects that
contribute to
uh generalizability uh and then
opportunities
for some of these models because of
their inherent flexibility in certain
cases
and you fine-tune them uh towards
certain use cases uh that are more local
or more
uh you know in one system for example i
think in general though there are both
machine learning approaches to this uh
problem of generalizability
but then also as your question points
out systematic
you know healthcare and data related
approaches and i think
there's a lot of movement on both fronts
um and a lot of conversations that has
frankly been catalyzed in some parts by
these new technologies really having
some impact but then also uh even more
recently catalyzed by
a use case like covid uh you know as we
sort of watch this pandemic
uh open up a lot of the opportunities
for data sharing
and development of models to try to
assist clinical care in some of these uh
some of these areas
that that really boils down to having
that again that baseline fundamental
understanding of how these tools work
where they don't what kind of data is
necessary uh and again that's really
what these courses will arm you with is
that
ability to to be very facile with again
the principles that that allow you to
think about these use cases and
anticipate problems and opportunities
great thank you matt um the next
question is
is the course just based on clinical
data analysis
or also insurance claims data
so in terms of the concepts we cover we
definitely
go beyond clinical insurance
and even other kinds of data
in terms of the capstone project it uses
simulated data
that mirrors what you might see as a
combination
of ehr and claims data has there been
any prediction models that have been
successful in predicting
cardiovascular events such as chf i'm
aware of google's work
in aki but nothing in the chf space and
i think this is directed towards
tina um
yes there are and in fact in in my
module
um in the course we go through several
um applications that actually have been
successfully deployed and regulated and
are on the market
um i don't know particularly which the
which the cardio which ones are
cardiovascular
um but that is something we cover in the
course and we walk through some examples
of ones that have been taken all the way
um through deployment regulation and and
dissemination across different sites
um the next question is
deployment of a prediction model on a
large scale is a huge
challenge given the heterogeneity of
population
across different regions genetic
composition physiology and ethnicity
how do you address this challenge as it
relates to scalable deployment
yeah i can go ahead and take that one
and so that's it that's a great question
and and this is exactly some of the
topics we we discussed
in in my course um it's important when
we're thinking about scaling across
populations that we
understand the particular biases in the
data
and and the ethical implications of
what we're predicting and so these are
all topics that um
that we go through in particular looking
at how data generated from
one population can be applied to another
population
and and how we can measure that and
evaluate that and evaluate the biases
and and potential some mitigation
strategies using
looking at algorithmic fairness
solutions
um another question about the program
in general someone had asked a major
challenge for students
upon entering the data science workforce
is data cleaning
if they primarily learned from clean
data sets
do your courses teach preliminary data
analysis
and cleaning approaches appropriate in
health care
uh that is not something we dive into in
this particular class uh
data cleaning and strategies to do that
is a
is a very broad topic and it would
probably require its own specialization
in terms of how or what are the
different kinds of issues that you might
need to face
so the short answer is no we do not
cover that other than bookmarking that
topic is important
and is your course usa health system
focused rather than
internationally and lauren you might
want to also
um jump in on this one
yeah i'm really happy to so um when in
my course we're trying to understand the
healthcare system and it's various
pieces how they work and so
in order to teach that in a way that
doesn't take you know months to cover we
pick one healthcare system to use as our
base and that's the u.s
system uh it turns out that the u.s
system is uh
good for us in a few different ways it's
pretty complicated so if you can
understand
that system uh you know of course you
then really understand the details of
one system but there are a lot of pieces
that
generalize to other places and a lot of
the general
kinds of lessons about different players
we we think and we hope are useful for
other systems
as i go through the u.s i also try to
call out different places
uh different different organizational
structures that exist outside the us and
that are related and so
so while it's focused on the us and i
think you'll get a really good strong
understanding of u.s systems
i hope that you can learn important
things that are applicable in other
systems as well
uh and and you know i think it's
generally true that a lot of the ideas
about healthcare delivery about
organizations about incentives are
pretty portable
so um so yeah u.s focus but with an
attempt uh to make it work across
multiple countries
too although we don't focus on any other
countries in specific terms
great thank you lauren um another
question um it looks like this is
from a current learner in the program
i'm currently taking the course it's
been great i'm an
occupational therapist very interested
in ai and how it can aid
allied health professionals
rehabilitation professionals
are you aware of groups working with ai
and allied or rehabilitation
health and is there work being done in
this field
so that's a great question um there i
mean i'm
i'm not an expert in rehabilitation or
occupational health by any means
i do know anecdotally of other research
on our campus
so i would particularly call out a
center called the mobilize center that
is
quite advanced in terms of using
artificial intelligence and simulating
people's movements and gait and so on
uh there's faculty in orthopedic surgery
who are
looking at variable devices like putting
them in shoes and
and so on and to monitor people's gait
and spinal issues
so i bet there is a community we can
find out more and share that uh
later but anecdotally i would say if you
start with the mobilize center at
stanford you might get
a hook into the options
thank you nick um this next question um
probably directed towards matt
and serena's course um do you think
imagine for example radiology retinal
imaging dermatology
ecg arrhythmia etc are most suited to
benefit from
ai
yeah i can speak from the from the
clinical perspective on that for sure i
think that um
there's reasons that there's advantages
that we're seeing now that maybe we
weren't seeing before so you know
there's a
again machine learning is obviously a
large uh
category and we try to cover a survey of
various types but certainly spend a lot
more time on deep learning as as it's
you know becoming incredibly useful
across different use cases
imaging in particular uh has a lot of uh
sort of um challenges if you don't have
networks or models that are capable of
handling what is essentially a large
amount of data
in in a systematic way and so that's
really where computer vision
techniques have really uh taken off and
and um
and yeah so i do think that imaging is
one very
uh very important area for this field
moving forward
and then transforming uh sort of the
practice of those of us that spend a lot
of time
as medical experts uh using imaging to
to help you know make diagnoses for
patients and again that's
as you suggested that's not just in you
know x-rays or mris that's also in
ophthalmology and dermatology
and again even even wave form tracings
and other things so
uh this this is why i think there's a
lot of excitement um and again we try to
really frame
uh our course as we go through the
different
types of models and different
fundamentals and principles
so that you know it would be sort of uh
very accessible to you
looking at a particular use case and
saying oh i think that you know this
series of models may work here
uh this may be uh you know potentially
one approach to
evaluate that and ensure that it works
etc so so that's really the goal and
again
to touch on the image we do spend a fair
amount of time on imaging use cases
because it as you're suggesting it is
very uh
illustrative of just the advantages of
these tools
um and just to add on to what matt's
saying i think that uh
yeah you know we're seeing a lot of this
uh
this the success in in imaging
especially with deep learning
uh because uh when deep learning
algorithms first started to
to show success um about you know seven
eight years ago
uh it was first designed for they were
variants
of deep learning algorithms designed for
image data um and so you know starting
six seven years ago we started to see
this spike
in just uh in success and just
state-of-the-art performance on image
data
um that being said in the past two or
three years or so
and we're trying to see kind of a
similar revolution of new deep learning
uh models now designed for uh sequence
data and particularly for
uh for text data um and so you know
while
right now image image success is still
really dominant um i do think that in
the coming years we're going to start to
see
more and more success in text data as
well
great thank you um if we have developed
ai models and tested them for accuracy
generalization and interpretability
academically what are the next steps we
should consider to even begin
trying to translate them to a clinic
anybody want to jump in on that one
sure i can take that one um and this is
something we go into
um deeply in in in my course and that's
talking about the steps of deployment so
after you evaluate the the performance
the
interpretability etc there's there's a
great need to understand
the clinical utility and and the
deployment costs
and so understanding how clinicians will
use your output
um how you're going to deliver that
output to the clinicians
and then and as we discussed we talk
about in silico deployment where we
actually deploy employee models and see
how that information is used and how
accurate is in real time prospectively
so there's a lot of steps with that and
and then of course after that we you
know you move on to scalability
and and and generalizability across
systems
so um we try to provide a framework in
my course to think about that entire
process
and um and walk you through the steps um
along the way so hopefully that that
that's helpful
thank you tina um we have time for one
more question here
um would you indicate a list of books
and or articles where
um we can go deeper into the subject
during and after
the program
does anybody have any suggestions on on
kind of learning more once they've
completed the program
so i'll jump in on this one uh and
tee off the last question which was once
you've done your evaluation
what next and uh there's a link to an
open source article that we can share
which is about a framework for making
predictive models useful in practice
which is essentially picking up
where this introductory specialization
ends to give you ideas on what you
should be thinking about
next uh there's obviously the option to
go down the path of getting deeper into
the technical details
and enroll in scpd programs uh
that would like get you hands-on
training
on working with data sets uh and
building models yourself so
you know after this entry point i would
say there's a little bit of a fork in
the road
whether you want to go more down the
health care side and utility
applications understanding why things
fit
or not or you can go down the how do i
build it side
and then we can share materials around
both but i would say an article might be
a good enough starting point
the other thing i would note is the
national academy of medicine
has released a report on ai
in healthcare which is about eight
chapters it's it's quite long
but the chapters are well organized you
can search by the titles and
that i would say is the one-stop shop
to get you sort of a menu of options and
names of people
and research and other articles to
follow and it's freely available
great thank you nick um so we're getting
to the end of our webinar here um so if
you'd like to learn more from the
faculty here today we encourage you to
join our ai and healthcare program
if you'll have more than 70 hours of
content to learn from them as well as
access to videos and
exercises to sharpen your skills
and again here is that link a link to
the recording of the session will be
emailed to you soon
so feel free to revisit this content
later
once again on behalf of the ai in
healthcare specialization
and the stanford center for health
education thank you for joining us today
we hope that you have a great week and
we hope to see you again in one of our
next sessions
thank you all
you